it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what's up Internet it's movie
fights thank guys for turn thank guys
for turning ladies welcome to the show
uh hi I'm your host Joe star we're doing
sort of a fun in the family all blind
fight questions this week you guys may
or not have seen on the internet define
media shutdown we're no longer
associated with define media so that
doesn't like necessarily affect us but
we do still sublease our space and some
of our equipment from Japan which now no
longer exists and so like we don't know
how long this out in the middle of this
show so so we were gonna have a
different fight today and hopefully
we'll be able to get back to that one
and this was gonna be our Thanksgiving
pre-tape but we were like you know what
no no principle so so I say let's say
I'm doing the show today was like a
little easier on us because we're
running around trying to figure out what
our homes gonna be for the next couple
of weeks
slash if there's not a movie fight next
week rest assured it will come back
we're just going to be briefly homeless
and that said much love to our friends
from clever Smosh warp zone all really
talented people that deserved a lot
better than they got this week that said
guys let's meet our fighters this week
first up you know from this seat its how
run neck ladies and gentlemen
hoot hoot owl nation what up where my
owls at the hooligans I like that you're
just 90's wrestling now you're just oh
yeah we're gonna be the rock in about
five years man it's gonna be good second
you know him from producing this show
and his podcast hot takes its Billy
business yeah I said I would never do
this again if it as my nutritionist
tells me I have no self-control
welcome back sir and but is side note to
our audience it's Billy's goal today to
not get to I'm trying to be chill if
you've ever seen me on TV fine so the
last time that was on movie fights I
apologize for yelling you at you dad's
okay we're not even on the show Dan so
today Michael just chill out so make
sure to let Billy know in the comments
if he's getting too angry and last but
not least you know him from being the
champion of this show it's Dan morale
high you know it would have been funny I
was thinking when you're like we still
sublet our studios and then it zoomed
out and we're on the back of a flatbed
the bank arrives in the middle of the
line today let's move this along because
they literally might come turn off the
lights let's meet our judges
it's London Calling over here it's lon
Harris and Daniel Radford lawn checking
the facts for us today
Thank You Sammy Percival against the
rules mom yeah says that you're on here
oh thank you
it says that your twitter is at Merle
Dam and the voice of the people Daniel
Radford hello um so as y'all know I am
the voice of view there will be places
that will be running that was a great we
love them please participate but the
polls for this match are the polls that
are on YouTube if you have any questions
about that ask them in the chat check
down the description box below those
polls will get read for the first before
we start going into the speed round
questions they only count in the case of
a tie and then if it winds up being a
three-way tie I have to be a person
which is not my favorite it is not your
favorite and also I'm the voice of y'all
sounds like a country cover of a seal
song I think let's run through the rolls
and let's get into the show this is a
best-of-seven total game a player needs
four points total through both the main
run and the speed around the win the
game in the event of a three-way tie or
just a three OS kick and going to the
speed round go to a tie
which will not count towards the final
score have jte do the thing
[Music]
Oh je te best doing the thing in the
business once again guys these are all
blind fights these guys don't know what
questions they're about to get hit with
this is gonna be a fun show so let's get
right into a question number one what
movie will win Best Picture in 2018 in
the 2018 Oscars what movie will win Best
Picture
how let's start with you buddy it's a
great question for this blind fight
what movie will win Best Picture in the
2018 Oscars you know there's a lot of
great films released this year and
there's there are some films that aren't
great that won't even be considered
they'll just fall by the wayside but I
think at the end of the day the Academy
they want to generate interest
popularity they want it to be a love
fest they want to dial up those ratings
that have been falling consistently last
year they hit record lows so I'm not
saying I agree with it but it's going to
be a star is born I am a star is born
okay Billy well hell I think that's a
terrible choice one that I definitely
it's a bold one that I don't think will
pay off for you I would have to say
given that that's off the table now
there's one thing that the Academy
really likes and that's movies by Damien
Chazelle and I'm gonna say even though
it wasn't maybe the financial success I
think that first man will walk away with
the Oscar this year it's got the
technical merits it's got slow brooding
pacing that old Academy voters love it's
got a follow-up to a movie that didn't
win when it thought it 1 mile island so
it's kind of he's old one he's old one
for the embarrassment I think
it's gonna be a mate good then I think
it's gonna be first man okay Dan Moreau
I think that best picture in an ideal
world is about rewarding the best film
of the year it's very tough it's very
subjective to figure out what is going
to be the best picture what's the name
the best picture like have you even
choose that luckily the Academy doesn't
have to do that cuz it's usually won by
whoever spends the most money to get
their film that award and that's why I'm
going with a movie I haven't seen yet
and nobody's seen yet outside of people
that went to the festivals
it's called Roma and Netflix has it and
I can't speak to the technical merits in
the film but a Netflix has it and
Netflix has the most money Netflix will
throw money behind any cause any show
anything in the world so I think that
they are going to put the most money
behind their movie and I think that Roma
will win best picture
bold choice Dan Morelle fight it out
gentlemen well tell you why it won't be
Roma because the academy is not going to
give the biggest award to a movie that
people can stay home and see it's going
yes it's going to be theatrically
released but a Netflix film is not going
to take that award because the Academy
wants to do the exact opposite get
people out to the theaters why would
they give the crowning achievement to
Roman even if it is one of the best
movies of the year why would they award
that with Best Picture because how
Academy Award voters themselves don't go
watch movies they watch every movie at
home so they're going to watch this
movie more than any of the other
screeners because they don't even have
to go to the mailbox and get the thing
out it's literally going to be on their
Netflix right here one idea where I just
say and I'm not trying to be a d-bag
here and part of the producers guild I
got my Netflix screeners already because
strangely they send discs Romo was not
one of them they sent kindergarten
teacher
they sent Roxanne Roxanne they have no
faith in Roma clearly and even if it's
Roma's great witch it very well could be
so was my bound I do think that there's
this stigma that Netflix equals poopoo
and things like the JR the Cloverfield
things like things like Mowgli which up
until yesterday was not even gonna have
a limited theatrical release there's
just a stigma that you put your poopy
movies on Netflix because they're not
good enough for a theater that's what
they used to say on HBO HBO was all Best
Picture face but it's be the Emmys
disrespect to each other matters
late-night porn you are incorrect
skinemax Showtime that ushered me
through my adolescence but um I just
cannot believe that they would reward
something that causes people to stay
home because they want to do the
opposite day you want these big
campaigns that's why they've expanded to
more than up to 10 films or what
happened is that because they were the
the gravy train is gonna stop rolling
through town if they didn't start
putting more popular movies than their
and I mean I'd love to hear about this
you know how let me let me say something
about a star is born if the question was
what will win best performance I don't
think you could touch Bradley Cooper but
if it was best song you got it but Best
Picture
the movies is one of my favorites but
it's not the best movie it's a great
performance that it holds isn't what is
best movie the question is what will win
and if there's one thing that's true
Hollywood likes to s its own D okay and
if you got Bradley Cooper handed down
the thought this is an old tired D that
has been asked through out the years I
think we are tired of guessing
blastaar is be I think they've seen it I
think we've seen it done better with
Judy Garland now first man oh my god the
pinnacle of the American Way it's the
one time we as people were like we can
do something that is bigger than
ourselves we saw it on the big screen
everything the cinematography you could
print out any frame of that movie and it
is gorgeous it's so stuffy and stiff
that the voters would be like I don't
know if I like this but I know this is
what great cinema is not a box-office
success it was the wrong kind of not a
box-office success but because it make
too much money to be a little indie
movie that the voters think they're
gonna be trendy if they vote for and it
didn't make enough money for it to be
popular enough for people to say like
people are gonna like me if I nominate
this we keep applying the Academy Award
standards as if they actually care about
which movies are the best it couldn't be
further from the truth they just want to
look good and that's why I don't think a
star is born is gonna win best picture
because it doesn't make a good story
now Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper are
gonna give great acceptance speeches and
those are the Oscars they're gonna give
that movie aroma is in black and white
it looks artsy it's directed by an Oscar
winner it's something that nobody will
really have seen it's the perfect Best
Picture whether it's the screener that
they're gonna be like oh well we'll skip
it where's my stars born
they can't they don't want to risk
picking one that no one's ever heard of
they're gonna go with been winning the
Oscars the last isync tit I've watched
every let me hit both those points
Hollywood loves remaking redoing a star
is born is the best impression of the
show me how many remakes win Best
Picture
I don't have time to go back and look it
all up but you're all prepared for this
fight how
this is a blind fight the very essence
of it is to be ill prepared but you said
the performances Bradley Cooper's
getting lauded for his directing all
those components the night is set up for
this big sweep of this movie that is big
box office but it bridges the gap often
times you have a big box office movie
and a movie that is critically acclaimed
and never the twain shall meet this
movie bridges the gaps it is the perfect
story for Hollywood's biggest night a
star is born it is like air in town
engines at the power of Lady gaga
imagine Clint Eastwood giving the best
picture to Bradley Cooper and the Hubble
team here's the thing how I think stars
borns can be one of those movies where
we roll into Oscar season and everyone
has their money on it but then the tide
turns because people are kind of sick of
it by that point we see it every year
where there's a front-runner that goes
in and everyone's like that's the one
it's gonna sweep and then it's like what
a shocking surprise they dare walk away
with anything that's what it's about the
same time everyone got bored that's what
this is gonna be with a stars board I
agree with Billy everyone's gonna go
into Austin I've been like a star is
born a star is born a star is born in
the academies like Bob we want to look
smart we're gonna give it to sign know
you smile and space movie there's
complex algorithms and things and chuck
boards and NASA and that's my technical
guilds are gonna love it and everybody
else is gonna own this is Stoll
of our history however your final
thoughts please and then Billy can roll
that monologue into yours okay Billy you
you've given me a lot of nuts and bolts
about first man but you haven't really
told me why it would win and in fact
first man is disappointingly
underwhelming they're not going to give
it to that I mean it would be nice be a
nice story for Damien Chazelle but he
will not see Oscar gold or a fake out of
Oscar gold roma is it's it's way too
small and it's on Netflix they do not
want to encourage people to stay home
this ceremony is it's a love letter to
the motion picture industry and a star
is born imagine all of the sequences
they can show the star is born
throughout the years and then top it all
off the cherry on the sundae
when this version takes it and they can
break their arms patting themselves on
the back and it is a rah-rah night for
Halle Hollywood which is what they want
because last year the ratings were crap
Billy all right so I think where the
star is born
you got the performances but you don't
have ultimately a great movie and I
think you have the hype for that movie
that's gonna work against it on yours I
think it's going to be completely missed
I don't even think it's gonna get
nominated for anything also I went to a
place called Tony Roma's and got food
poisoning yeah I think that my movie is
there Goldilocks between the two if it's
not it's artsy fartsy which they love
but not so artsy fartsy that no one's
gonna watch it but it also has Damien
Chazelle which they already love so it's
got it's got the hype behind it it also
is a great movie with great
cinematography everything's beautiful
the music is beautiful it's a beautiful
story about a man grieving in the midst
of one of the greatest achievements of
human history and I think that Damien
Chazelle he's owed one for the whole
mishap and
they're gonna say you know what this
year's the year to do it let's just give
give him an attaboy for that one and all
of those points would be good if they
gave this based on merit belly but they
don't first of all the the argument that
my picture is too small to win best
picture
that's not sure that might have been
true 20 years ago but that's a that's an
Oscar of a bygone era how small is in
that's what they want to get Best
Picture - that's what they've been given
Best Picture - and the Academy wants
nothing more than to look relevant a
stars born is a dinosaur it's one of
those old-timey big studio movies that
if they give it to him it's going like
well yeah of course the Oscars gave it
to a stars born that's what they do
there the Oscars you know what makes
them relevant means they have to look
cool and what makes them looking cool
giving it to Netflix oh you give it to
Netflix how ng how groundbreaking COO
and that all the Academy gets off on
that oh my god they just want to look so
groundbreaking edgy like macho man in
touch they're gonna break the mold
they're gonna buck Convention they're
gonna get that dinosaur out of there
they don't care about yours it's too dry
there's no heart in it they couldn't get
behind it they want to go with the cool
movie they want to look cool it's a
younger academy there's a young hip
Academy but give it to the Netflix movie
that's how they're gonna prove who they
are that's the grandparents have given
to a star is born this Academy's the
cool Academy's
diggin tower power too sweet to be sour
lon
what are the facts and how you feeling
I'm feeling great to two facts one is
they're easy remake that has won Best
Picture one remake this according to the
Guinness people the departed Martin
Scorsese the department also a fact that
I saw come up a few times in the chat
room the moon-landing fake so it's fair
didn't really land on the moon Buzz
Aldrin how simple the Illuminati lon
who's got your vote this was tough I
thought all three fighters did a really
good job it really sort of oddly Betty
came down to how and Dan for me cuz I
just thought Billy did a great job
marketing my first night was a really
good sort of overlooked movie but I
thought dad and help both sort of got
him on kind of an underwhelming movie
wasn't it really sort of beloved or
taken up by audiences and I think
audiences might forget it by the time
the Oscars actually come around it was
really back and forth between Halland
Dan I thought Dan's final closing
argument was really strong and did make
a case that this Academy may want to
give it to something a little bit less
traditional Hollywood something from a
studio like Netflix so I'm going with
that okay yeah first I do want to throw
out props to Billy for two things donuts
the D of a star is be great and I think
that's going to be another films counter
advertising campaign
I also love the Goldilocks metaphor but
it did also come down to Dan have with
me as well and it's interesting because
for a movie that Dan has not seen the
fight the argument against Romo didn't
get too far beyond they're not going to
give it to a Netflix movie so that that
back and forth was interesting and I
really enjoyed that argument about this
is this is the Academy that's going to
look cool but there was just a little
more of a complete sad disappointing
picture to me of an Academy who hey
there's the Goblet here it is it's set
up you know Bradley Cooper's been handed
Excalibur by Clint Eastwood and blah
blah blah know Lady gaga it's a love
letter to the industry that it was just
a really really good argument to me so
I've got a vote Hal which means Danielle
what are the people think her fans
well well Joe the the fans just want to
take another look at you they got stars
born at 56% Romo at 23% and first man at
20% okay so that first round going to
mr. Howe Rudnick um and over on these
socials a lot of people talking about
greenbook yeah a lot of people think oh
that one should get it so I gotta find
it I lost it unfortunately but someone
made a great meme that that's just a
picture of Joe hitting first of all and
saying I don't give a hoot
that lives now threatens to pollute does
not want to know who how many licks it
takes to do you want to go party the
building me and Grove though question
number two hey guys this question no
real inspiration here we made round
cards for this we've all worked for some
terrible companies what would be the
worst fictional movie company to work
for
mmm what would be the worst fictional
movie company to work for Billy we're
starting with you I'm gonna say I don't
know if this counts does the empire
count there are a lot of places where
unsavory things happen in the workplace
and I think my competitors will give
examples of that but there are very few
places least that we're aware of or if
you do a bad job there's gonna choke you
out and they're going to kill you and
then people are not gonna be terrified
and be like we need to set up a union
here we need to do something they're
gonna drag your corpse out and then
they're going to just take your place
cutthroat competition sometimes
literally a horrible mission statement
all around terribleness I think the
Empire would just be the pits man this
are like pits Dan indeed I'm so many
corporations went through my head and
what what can I pick what could I choose
I'm going to go with OCP
from Robocop you have all the
disadvantages of working for a
corporation and a like black bag
military a dark web industrial complex
company
I think the instability at the top of
that is very troubling if you're a rank
and file employee on top of it all I
don't really know what they do and I
don't think anyone else really does
either and so not not a fun place to
work if you're asking me no thank you
okay how you know when I want to enter a
fictional movie universe and work at a
company I want an experience that is
going to be different that's going to be
exciting that's going to be visceral
none of those will occur in fact it'll
be the exact opposite and I could not
imagine working for the company in
office space
mmm going with the company and office
space from office space okay company
from off space Galactic Empire and OCP
gentlemen fight it out
hell I think the worst risk at your job
is just being bored and honestly they
really don't care if you decide to screw
around because that guy did it and got
promoted so yours actually sounds
awesome because I can go there screw
around and probably have a better life
for myself dan I applaud innovators that
sometimes you have to break some eggs to
make an omelet but I think those guys
they come up with some great technology
they're risk takers they're trying to
make some big changes in the world of
policing and security maybe it didn't
quite work out but you know what damn it
they're trying when the Empire by the
way you can't get away from the Empire
as we saw Galen or so in rogue one he
worked for the Empire he tried to get
away oh they just found him and they
killed him and they brought him right
back you cannot put in your two weeks if
you work for the Empire they will come
and they will find you that is the worst
condition when you can't even quit let
me tell you one thing it is better to
lived for one day than to have never
lived at all and if you go to work for
that company in office space it is death
it is ennui it is being in the maze job
they give you constant K constant cake
in the break room you're in outer space
I could be a pilot I could be a laser
shooter when you're jenna siding whole
planets and that's your job today who
knows what those planets are you
advocating genocide war is not pretty
this is not a pretty thing here's the
thing about initech though what can you
do at initech you can fail upwards yes
all you saw happy to initech if you were
incompetent if you're bad at your job
literally the guy that was actively
trying to get fired
what's promoted that's the kind of job
that I want I want to dick around and
then pretend like I've got some
brilliant business strategy and get a
better salary that sounds incredible
yeah but if I go to work at your company
like I get to see like amazing stuff
like 209 boys at Omnicorp who saw the
ed-209 what their takeaways are things
serious was cuz let me promise you it
was not plungers the things that's a day
a talk about truth upwards at Omni
consumer products your your the the
probability that you're going to get
blown out of the window by a half
cybernetic cop goes
one to advance in this community the
body count Rises the hires you go member
here's the thing Dan a lot of these
companies and we all know you are held
down because your jerk of a boss just
keeps climbing up the ladder for no
reason how great would it be if you came
back from the means like oh he got blown
away he's not there anymore
yes you just took out my boss while
installing cameras and police officers
which we should be doing it ran amuck
can you imagine being a stockholder and
Omni consumer products all my stock
dropped 50% today what happened the CFO
fell from the top of a high-rise company
townhome I should just disappear from
your comments bestest today aren't you
happy no why not rubble come to kill
half the city you don't want to work for
this company my company has that both of
yours don't have is a terrible effing
dress code I have to go to work in the
the tightest plastic white armor or a
big freakin helmet that I can't see
anything out of or itchy gray wool that
is terrible everyone dress it wants to
dress up like that for comic-con and
Halloween do Abed the break rooms gonna
smell with all those freaking people in
those hot costumes it's evil how badly I
want to wear a cape to work
but I can work Kate for you're not Darth
Vader you're not critic you'll get no
cape you're totally mobile Dan is
upwardly mobile notice I will say that
the only people who got choked out at
the Empire were those who prove
themselves and capable of doing their
jobs properly
I am confident in my skills I'm
confident that I can get the job done if
what's asked of me I think I would damn
Caelian not being able to fail at a job
is why we have so many people making
mistakes and afraid to admit to them I
wouldn't be able to learn on the job I
can't learn at the Empire because I
might die if I make a mistake that is
not a place for me to grow in my
professional career you know if you're
that afraid go talk to HR and the elbows
don't waiter there's a hundred percent
Empire HR that young is all middle
management the Empire is 85% middle
management which is a wonderful place to
build a nice probably a pension
somewhere and then they send you to
freaking Yavin or someplace where you're
never gonna get out of there here's what
I have to say your job is probably most
ideal because you can go to your work
goof around and get rewarded for it
there's also cake and flashy staplers I
see almost no downside here then I think
that the police have a tough job to do
and in this day and age you have to be
resourceful and you're gonna make some
mistakes but sometimes a Robocop pans
out and Robocop turned out to be the
hero in the end of the movie anyway so I
qualify that as a win my job you cannot
fail
you can't quit because they'll find you
terrible dress code no benefits probably
no pension I don't know one can you fact
check of Stormtroopers get pension and
by the way at any moment you could have
a terrorist cell of rebels who are just
gonna blow you up you're like men I'm
just an accountant for the Empire don't
blow up the ship I'm on I didn't do
anything wrong
there's always a risk factor for being
in the Empire that you have to assume
Dan there's risk factor in almost every
job plus the Empire offers travel you
could see the stars many parts of the
galaxy and like I said yes there are
some people some parts of the Empire
that have had some run-ins with the
rebels but you're not seeing the vast
majority of the workers for the Empire
they're just people scraping out a
living and some planet on the outer rim
and then they heard that the Empire was
done and they're like okay whatever I'm
just gonna be a farmer now it's fine
you're really making out to be worth it
at is how your job again
initech offers nothing but rewards for
the least possible amount of work that
you can do I can't think of a better
setup than that and my job is part of a
quasi-military unit that was not
actually trying to improve the police as
a matter of fact they caused a police
strike good luck working through the the
barrage of lawsuits from the people of
Detroit who weren't served well you know
great you built a Robocop but there are
no other cops on the streets Robocop
can't fix every single crime and it's
completely unstable it's untenable half
of the upper management died in the
first movie you kid this is not the
company you want to work for it is
nothing but instability lawsuits and
mass destruction this is a terrible
place to work now run it could you read
me the question one more time please
we've all worked for some terrible
companies going after what would be the
worst fictional movie company to work
for okay so when desire dies what is
left this company would neuter or spay
if you're um
lady animal your desire your will to
live your company damn they are rich MF
errs and they are building the future
there's a lot of fun crap to be around
and I like plus like there's cocaine
parties and stuff and like you probably
get to meet the guy who says I buy that
for a dollar Billy and and it's turnin
Detroit around what a noble cause Billy
I can't wait fire blasters you get to
travel I think Dan made a lot of good
points about why it could be awesome to
work for the Empire and your point about
the dress-code moot that got it's great
they got a great dress code in the
Empire who doesn't want to dress like
like a fricking stormtrooper wear those
those slick ass boots plus-size
stormtrooper how they don't make them
for bigger dudes
[Laughter]
[Music]
so yeah your your company's both are
offer excitement I want to venture into
the fictional worlds this one Oh kill me
now with office space
all right time ho gentlemen excellent
fight star later Star Wars calm they
confer there is an imperial HR Human
Resources Kapiti embodies a cool take
now retirement benefits in the short
story secret weapon which lets to the
force awakens a spy actually tracks a
stormtrooper down to a retirement home
indicating there are some retirement
bearing is that book if we're going to
the star of a separate TV show he's not
connected
specifically in future to treasure your
carefree I gotta make it effortless
alright okay so you guys laid out a lot
of points that you said with your words
how I love the passion man but man they
really danger on cake just the general
ability to fail upwards you know just
just all the marks of a very terrible
company when you're able to do something
like fail upwards just just the pits but
not the worst not the worst man so this
kind of this this came down to Billy and
Dan for me you really fought back well
Dan with with the point about that they
will didn't in fact improve
the city they the company actually
wasn't doing his job they got in the
police way that caused a police strike I
thought that was a really great ding
against that argument but then there's
also something about the empire not let
not allowing you to put in two weeks
like you literally can't quit that job
but you know that got dinged by a little
bit with you know capes are pretty cool
and whatever I say at the end of the day
Dan got my point when he said there were
well five but I got to give this point
today in laundry voting all right I kind
of describe me I thought I thought
everybody you know sort of some good
points that I agree with I agree that
met Holly it's just it's a little bit
too much like a normal company we have
these sort of very big impressive
dangerous crazy companies to work for
but I actually thought ultimately Dan
made a great case for why OCP is a
terrible company and their mission isn't
gonna succeed but I've really made the
stronger case for why it would be worse
to work specifically at the Empire so
I'm going Billy okay okay I always liked
you on we're tied up be on the bottom
floor
Danielle that means we've got to go to
our own galactic storm troopers to
figure out who's breaking this tie oh
well it's 57% we have the Empire Star
Wars and 31% we've got OCP and at 10%
we've got the office from office space
by the way Dan that was a fantastic
choice I had not very solid but but
ultimately meaningless on Twitter as
well at studio executives spelled
exactly the way it sounds but nothing at
the end said Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory no benefits hazardous work
conditions and your job is out sourced
by small orange people at the drop of a
hat
mm-hmm dangerous yeah that was one I saw
come up a bunch into the company freezer
nice pass dinosaur of course maybe but
you know you think it would be bad to
work for the company just from alien I
was thinking what would you tying again
yeah yeah bad place to work yeah I'm
killing this banter right now Ellie wins
the round that means Hal and Billy
you've got to point apiece Dan Merle
coming up from behind I got faith in you
sir that's why you're the champ question
number three is a double-blind fight you
never get to find out what the questions
are
no guys I'm gonna ask you to pick an
Internet phrase out of this hat out of
this great Tron helmet pick a phrase out
of the Hat I'm just one that's just one
I believe I don't know what this now I'm
gonna ask you to read your phrases Dan
well we'll start with you since uh we're
starting with our third chair here I
don't know what this means either I'm
just gonna give it the inflect the
inflection that I hear in my head okay
which is [ __ ] I might be okay yeah well
I don't know do we want it and do it are
we allowing can we check in with our
judges I think that's fine yeah that's
great okay um Danielle on ask me a
question Danielle are you gonna be on
movie fights next week [ __ ] I might be
ma'am okay Gucci Mane was asked I
believe that it was about well he was I
yeah what yes the judge asked him if he
was guilty and he said [ __ ] I might be
humane um he's an actor from Spring
Breakers among other things my my phrase
is squad goals okay and Billy Mize
another one I don't know what this means
this slaps
don't tell me about a song that you like
oh okay alright gentlemen please pitch
the movie adaptation of that phrase
please pitch the movie adaptation you
can give me the director you can give me
the lead the cast the story Wow me it's
the movie adaptation of [ __ ] I might be
okay interesting okay I think is the
proper utilization phraseology involved
with this phrase it's important I'm
seeing this as a comedy I'm seeing this
as a comedy vehicle for Billy Eichner
long long sense long sense due for I
think a feature-length comedy vehicle
and I think this is a movie called the
coy detective it's a crime drama it is a
an opportunity for him to portray a
crime fighter who is working under the
guise of you know like a pie and his
answer to like what are you some kind of
cop or something is which I might be I
see it as a great opportunity to we need
some classic comedies these days we
haven't had a good four quadrant comedy
in a while and I see this being a big
hit thank you Dan how run it the
apocalypse has happened we are in a
wasteland there are survivors there are
groups that are placed together not by
choice but by happenstance of
circumstance after the great Apocalypse
which is a natural disaster slash
nuclear holocaust all at once
there is one safe Bastion and these
separate groups are headed to see who
can achieve this safety first in this
oasis and there's only room for one
group one Squad if you will its Mad Max
fury road meets it's a mad mad mad mad
world the classic comedy meets
Cannonball Run those last two were
pretty similar hashtags wakile's hashtag
squad goes Billy this slaps I'm gonna
take you I'm gonna take you back to the
magical year of 1992 or maybe it was 3
or 4 somewhere in that time period
it's the final climactic game between
the Blackhawks and the Ducks and coach
Riley tells his players this kid scores
a goal none of you will make the hockey
team next year and we all know what
happens those Mighty Ducks they took
home that winning trophy I think that's
what hockey does where does coach Riley
go next year he's already fired all of
his peewee players enter the prequel
reboot spin off this slaps coach Riley
has to get a whole new team of hockey
players but also he has to learn because
coach Riley I think is one of the most
despicable characters in all of film
that's right all of film and I think not
only does he have to learn that winning
isn't everything but he has to put
together a team that he can win finally
the peewee championships fair and square
so he can go back to Gordon Bombay and
say you taught me and you know what this
team right here that I'm looking at none
of you cheated none of you did the wrong
thing you did this with heart and you
know what I think that slaps
gentlemen find it out so let me tell you
a little bit more about that slaps
because right now
nostalgia is current and anything that
came out in the 90s we don't care what
it is if there's any sort of sequel we
will go see it guess what and be
disappointed is still in the air I see
people on the street saying quack quack
quack all the time
you can't that check that try so there's
so many things in the streets
Disney is mining old properties this is
the perfect way to get those cameos back
from Emilio Estevez because everyone
wants the Mighty Ducks for this is a way
to do the Mighty Ducks franchise bring
it back but also close out the circle of
coach Riley
give a despicable character a new life
because what do we love to do in this
new age we take our our biggest villains
and we humanize them that's what Disney
does best they want to humanize coach
Riley this slaps it's like a whole new
Bad News Bears because we remake that
movie every 10 years whether you like it
or not and that's what this is going to
be Billy the world has moved on the
world thinks it's nostalgic The
Incredibles that's about as far back as
they go this is going to be a depressing
rug being pulled out from under some
place that's the sort of beloved this is
this is camaraderie and team and sports
that that never gets old how many years
do we see these sports comedies come out
where it's the same tropes but we love
it because it's familiar to us put it
with the familiar IP baby let's just
start pretty money right now during guy
I barely worked on YouTube read Bob Iger
is going to cross this off of his
spreadsheet yesterday this is not a cash
grab if you're gonna do the remaining
ducks you get a remake the Mighty Ducks
you're not gonna take a tertiary
character that nobody remembers from the
fur you're gonna get a Lee west of us
then you're gonna recast them then you
can recast the Mighty Ducks from
whatever Evers in the Disney Channel
mill right now and that's gonna be your
Mighty Ducks reboot it's not gonna be
let's take the coach from the losing
team yeah
that's what this this franchise is all
about it's about taking the losers and
making them whole you can't do that what
the Mighty Ducks cuz they're already
winners so how do you still play in the
Mighty Ducks franchise there Alfred your
movie is a movie that I feel like I've
seen a million times a hundred thousand
movies popped in my head when you said
yours I'm tired of the apocalypse the
apocalypse is played out anything with
squad in the title is poopoo already I'm
gonna have to listen that's the answer
that's the answer about squad that is
his tag line you were the one that
decided to make that your title you
didn't have to I thought it was blank
the movie and I'll stick with this I'll
choose this squad goes it's about time
we had squad goals the movie and imagine
this squad
Daniel Kahlua Tilda Swinton no Aquafina
Dolph Lundgren okay they are racing
towards this mythical Oasis that is in
the desert will they achieve say I'll be
racing towards the bargain Ben no one is
going to go see this movie it was a
phrase that most people in their minds
tie to a misspelled tattoo done by
Margot Robbie two years ago squad goals
died with Suicide Squad that was long
been a hash tagging squad goes all the
time I'm gonna turn gonna happen squad
goals the people that are gonna my mom
has never cast in a cash bagging this
joy might be
first of all I'm actually glad that
Billy brought up the title because he
says that I didn't name my movie that
now in my head I see myself driving down
Beverly Boulevard with a picture of
Billy Eichner and [ __ ] I might be right
next to him and it sells it sells I'm
gonna ask you a question are you
thinking about changing the title of
your movie I think it might be changed
too [ __ ] I might good because it works
and we talk about something that's it
lady how does it work with the talent
that you assembled Oh goals that sounds
like it's gonna be a parody of Twitter
is what it sounds like [ __ ] I might be
wrong perfectly with my cow movie no you
want to talk about something that's
played out it's um a Oh funny cop movie
a cop gun a cop gone rogue a silly cop
oh I shouldn't be a cop but I am how
many of those have we seen a cop out
others the recent cop out didn't work is
because it was anchored by the least
funny person in the world Bruce Willis
if I can think of someone I wanted to
kill a movie quicker I would cast Bruce
Willis telecine you're fine Hobson cop
movies have been personality-driven for
decades now Beverly Hills Cop wasn't
some remarkable breakthrough in the cops
your honor it worked because of Eddie
Murphy Lethal Weapon worked because of
Danny Glover and Mel Gibson the cops on
rapper ticularly when you're talking
about one that's a comedy is driven by
the strength of your casting I think
with this catchphrase with the premise
of the movie and with the casting you
have a package that's gonna be funny
it's gonna actually be a good movie the
brand works with what I'm adding to it
and it might actually be something fun
and can like just we need it's like a
big studio comedy there's so few good
ones I think if you get Billy Eichner on
board you get [ __ ] I might be on
Billboard's across the country you've
got a recipe for success I think yours
first of all that's an insane cast
secondly your genre doesn't even fit
when it's called thirdly the the tagline
is is three years too late and then this
slaps again it is he's gonna do
something with the Mighty Ducks they're
not gonna remake it using the coach from
the other team that nobody remembers
they're just gonna remake the Mighty
Ducks because there's way more money
this slaps
transient value as far as like marketing
the Mighty Ducks is what they're gonna
lean into and it's just gonna be called
the Mighty Ducks or Mighty Ducks they'll
leave a thought out or put it on the end
or whatever they do when they read
everything these days
Wow final thoughts on squad goals when
you were selling your genre you
mentioned two movies from the beginning
of the funny buddy cop genre from over
30 years ago since then it has become
stale and it's become tired and we don't
need to see another guy oops I'm doing
this job but I shouldn't be I'm a spy
but I shouldn't be I'm a cop and I
shouldn't be it's a super tired genre he
was about by the way here you know
projecting onto money you said it was a
cop I said he was a cop but that says
that's what my movie was gonna be okay
please no more editorializing during
final thoughts so yes so yeah it's
really played out in kind of DOA and I
agree Billy you picked the wrong
character to follow and that sounds like
maybe a Disney Channel special movie to
be played late at night after High
School Musical 3 or something like that
like it doesn't sound like something
that could carry a film that is also
it's too tired and it would like cut the
knees out from a beloved property this
combines so much fun and action you get
these different groups racing towards
this prize which is their ultimate
survival you get practical awesome Mad
Max style chases and some Cannonball Run
mad mad mad mad world seeing these
different groups going after this prize
how much fun would that be and you got
the action and acting with Daniel Coolio
Tilda Swinton Dolph Lundgren and then
the humor with Aquafina thrown in there
oh man what a journey what a ride
squad goals and belly let's hear your
final thoughts on this last
Daniel if I strive down and I here's
that here's the problem with [ __ ] I
might be you you have to two different
scenarios one someone of my age or maybe
a little bit younger sees [ __ ] I might
be in roles their eyes off hears them
trying to be cool and relevant that
looks like a terrible movie or vice
versa
a parents like [ __ ] I might be [ __ ]
I'm not taking my kid to that movie
because it has [ __ ] in the title you
just sucks the four-quadrant out of your
movie by changing it to [ __ ] I might be
also I don't really even know what your
movie is because it's just Billy Eichner
being sassy that's your movie I have no
idea what it's about how you basically
I'm kind of in the same boat here you
just said it's it's essentially rat race
which is a terrible movie but in the
apocalypse you didn't really give me
anything about your movie and you also
said that this slaps sounds like a
Disney Channel original movie which I
know you meant as a dig but I wear that
as a badge of effing honor because you
know what you mention High School
Musical where do you think that started
homeboy that started in my school
musical 1 & 2 on the Disney Channel
that's how you introduced this property
back Disney Channel original movies or
nothing to scoff at you can't do Mighty
Ducks without Gordon Bombay and you
don't know if you're going to but he
might show up for a cameo like you did
in Mighty Ducks 3 so how do you get
around it you reintroduce the team that
couldn't beat the Mighty Ducks so that
he can have that full circle thing and
then on top of that you have the 90s
nostalgia so parents now want to take
their kids because they're like oh
Mighty Ducks I love that I'll go spend
money on anything from the 90s and kids
are just gonna love it for what it is
because they don't know any better
your guys's for pie-in-the-sky pitches
mind something that could potentially
actually happen in as a movie whether
you like it or not time gentlemen
three excellent films all that I hope to
see back Jack's is Lane Smith the great
character actor who plays coach Jack
Riley passed away in 2005 so we will
have to do all I'll say is if we can get
Tarkin and rogue one we can get lanes
there's ways around it
we can also recast I feel like recasting
maybe in that scenario as opposed to
digitally all right lon where's your
boat leaning you know I the whole time I
was pretty much behind just one of them
and then did not waver
I feel like [ __ ] I might be was the
movie to be out of these three cop drama
Billy Eichner that title I wanted to see
that movie and not as hard as they try
Billy a now could not sway me daddy gets
my vote okay one vote for [ __ ] I might
be first of all I feel like I'm seeing
devil because you picked a weird choice
that I feel like I would make and then
you just made a pen disintegrate in your
hand
both of you channeling me a little bit
Billy that was such a terrible idea
yes it was but damn it just you just
wouldn't let it die
I didn't hear enough about about
squabble Cecilia I got sort of an
interesting cast and I got sort of
movies that it feels like so this was
that this was between this laughs and
[ __ ] I might be hey and I'm not one
who's ever gonna want to vote against
Billy Eichner but right there at the end
with the comeback on the Disney Channel
rebuttal and that's where High School
Musical came from man I and also the
fact that changing the title back to
[ __ ] I might be kills your
four-quadrant your four-quadrant pitches
as passionate and as clear as that
elevator pitch was I've got a vote for
this stupid
like a badge of Disney Channel original
movie honor so that takes it that takes
us to the pillow like bees where they
sway in pitch in the title um at 78 it's
with squad goals 8% for Billy this slaps
can I just say there is nothing more
than listening to dance a [ __ ] I think
it's the best thing a couple of great
comments they were so many but at GI t
underscore Shi ddy yeah I know what
you're doing and I rise above movie
fights live blind flights round three
brought to you by urban dictionary and
she built a myth well squad goals has
the movie poster right here which is a
movie you guys you got to go over to his
Twitter
it is the buddy cop comedy of hoot hoot
and chop-chop I did wrote that was not
that was meant to be a commentary on
myelination
you cannot destroy an expanded universe
I do want to see I do want to see movie
posters for all three of these films but
that said gentlemen we have a three-way
tie let's get our tiebreaker on boy hey
sick-ass Star Wars news you guys there's
gonna be a Disney streaming Star Wars
show about Cassie and and/or he's been
in this fight
since he was six years old what Disney
movie should become a series on the
Disney streaming service not just pitch
that yeah isn't that weird so again guys
the way this works is you'll each give
your answer you'll have 20 seconds to
argue and then a a 10-second rebuttal
yeah yeah I never watch the show and
then the best answer will move forward
how we're gonna start with you sir is no
it's not yell it out yeah this answer
first yeah sorry again I don't watch our
product how answers first we'll answer
I'm going Incredibles okay Billy's going
Incredibles Toy Story Toy Story
the last time I was in the Tiber Septim
name as the lovebug ooh love lug okay so
we've got Incredibles Toy Story and Love
Bug bill you answered first because
that's how the game works and it's a
game that I've watched before yeah
you're answered first Billy 20 seconds
one of the most successful things that
Disney does is make shows of their
biggest hit cartoons a big hero 6 is a
big hit for them they do it all the time
with their stuff Incredibles lends
itself to that because there's a whole
world of villains that we don't get to
see in a two-hour 90-minute movie of
Incredibles each week and being a
different adventure we can focus more on
individuals or bring them all together
for big episodes the potential is that a
toy story this will be an anthology
series where we follow different toys
and different kids bedrooms and we in
different kids toy boxes and we will get
visits from some of the old original
toys it's got the best of both worlds
then at the end these different toys
that we represent can come together for
a cause to fight an evil toy that's
trying to infiltrate I think Herbie the
lovebug would work on Disney Plus was
what they're calling it don't do it
trust me is that is that Herbie use is a
character but really it can be any kind
of adventure a week-to-week
Herbie can take the people that are
inside you don't just have these
characters you have the people inside
her be going from place to place you
don't have a set format which means it's
not gonna get stale you can have chases
you can have action you can 10-seconds
Billy when you're ready
kala doesn't work in short chunks
they've tried it with Buzz Lightyear
Star Command that's bad the shorts are
not as charming as they think they are
dan if you think they know anything less
than the blackout's it's gonna be Herbie
the lovebug nobody knows what that is
nobody cares nobody
new journeys new toys The Incredibles we
already have the thundermans that's
basically at show already on TV Herbie
the lovebug not a popular property the
the remake was DOA and the same people
all about Toy Story is those characters
in that talent they're gone you're not
you're not everything to everyone you're
anything to nobody cuz you're not fight
featuring either new ones all the way or
old ones all the way an Incredibles it's
best at scale and they don't have the
budget to keep that kind of scale
Incredibles is it lazy because looks
great oh all right gentlemen first of
all well thought and I agree a Disney
Plus would be a choice that a terrible
company would make your streaming
service well you were timing lon there
were no it there no but what's your vote
man so we're picking who should be
eliminated yes yes oh you were top I've
ever watched thanks Jeff yeah Wow I
definitely for me this came down to
Howell vs. things I thought Billy did a
great job and The Incredibles just right
to me is huge universe so much to
explore ultimately I feel like how make
kind of I think an error with the
anthology I think that the thing people
want to see out of a show turning out
from a movies the characters the
scenarios the settings that they love so
in this case I think how is the one that
would not progress to the speaker after
me okay yeah so the interesting thing to
me was all three of you sort of pitched
a slightly different take on their gonna
explore the larger world of this
franchise and the only one of you who
was really able to ding that really well
sort of at the end was Dan so Dan is
going to stay so then it sort of became
to me in a fight between its anthology
about different toys versus it's an
anthology about different superheroes
Hal I'm sorry sir but you're stepping
out of this out of this tie well fought
sir all right hey
nation and that means we're entering our
speed round
stay awake outrun it because I'm gonna
come in to you for thoughts/opinions
commentary just al sounds oh sure gonna
come to you for all of them so again a
player needs a total of four points
between the main rounds of the speed
round to win the game you guys are
currently tied at 1-1 same rules applies
before the answer whoo ants the player
who answers first gets twenty seconds to
answer the second person also gets
twenty seconds and then you get ten
second rebuttal you guys have seen this
game before I have - I'm starting to
remember
okay so speed around question number one
oh and of course Danielle just the voice
of her own person now just the voice of
her own person some day you're gonna
start to believe in that person Daniel I
know I do speed around question number
one powering the cow
what movie character would make the best
Doctor Who companion what movie
character would be the best doctor on
the brain I can't imagine why Tony Stark
this is hard I don't know doctor it's
the time travel buddy I will say Ted
from Bill and Ted literally a travel
button
alright yourselves I said literally a
time yeah 20 seconds on Tony Stark Dan
when you're ready I feel like this
beloved this doctor who is even its
biggest fans would admit that the show
can go up its own butthole a little bit
too much and I think that if you have a
character like Tony Stark as a companion
that he can sort of take take it a
little less seriously and comment on how
ridiculous some of that stuff is and
that would be welcome but also draw in a
bigger audience plus you don't want to
see Tony Stark in the doctor teaming up
to fix the TARDIS roll up their sleeves
and doing doodads and gizmos under there
now of the three episodes I've seen of
Doctor Who I'm pretty sure that this is
mostly about just going to places in
time and learning something and maybe
stopping something that's what the
doctor does but the companion all you
have to do is just be someone who's
jolly and fun and can have an adventure
Ted's already done that he's he knows
what he's in for he's gonna be a great
companion because time travel doesn't
faze him in fact he's really into it
Tony starting to be a d-bag Tony Stark's
gonna add some much-needed commentary
we've seen Doctor Who with a naive
companion and we've seen Ted travel
through time so you're pitching to
things that we've already seen before I
want something fresh something original
something that's gonna breathe new life
into the show but in a fun way Tony
Stark has already proved that he doesn't
work well with doctors and that he's
gonna just go off and do his own thing
you also don't need a tech guy because
the little one thingy the wrench fixes
everything whereas my companion is just
along for the ride
this one I thought the angle on why Tony
Stark would be a good companion to the
doctor was a really actually solid
argument for a wife should be for such a
sort of silly throwaway question my vote
goes to Dan Lunt
yes great an argument as Tony Stark
doesn't work well with doctors
overall I think I gotta go with that I
did actually find the discussion of what
that would be like very compelling I
would watch that grasping at straws
there what character would you pick to
go time-traveling with a with a
delightful Brit Tiffany Haddish from
girls trip I'd watch her just like Alex
yeah that would make that would make the
show more watchable for me Church or
true okay so we are uh danezaa
one-billion those go on still dansgame
yeah let's get to our second question
speed around question number two who's
the best movie dog who's the best movie
dog shadow homeward bound mmm [ __ ] from
Lady and the [ __ ] hmm when you're ready
Billy
[Laughter]
when I'm thinking about a great movie
dog there's two things that I want the
cube factor and the wisdom I want a dog
that's that quite literally been around
the block but he also is the glue of
that family that animal family he keeps
them together he is the heart and soul
of that movie he's the one that gets
them to the promised land he takes them
all the round men or montana wherever
the hell they are
he gets the job done shadows great but
he's falling his instincts which is what
the animals do what I like about the
[ __ ] is he street smart and he's able
to navigate ladies through this world
you know he could have been like Oliver
Twist thing where she's trying to like
take advantage every but no he's like
actually trying to show her how to
survive plus he finds a family and he
gives her a family he's the other half
ladies a little bit too prissy he's a
little loose a little bit too shrimp
isn't even the coolest Disney dog bolt
and Dodger are cooler than [ __ ] also
shadow is also it doesn't not [ __ ] but
he's really wise I think they need to go
he's the coolest Disney dog he's also
adorable that wasn't the coolest Disney
dog shrimp is good Billy Joel for Pluto
and gets Pluto socks
Oh Billy you just Roth Danielle we're
starting with you who you got I love
this question this is a great question
could've done a whole show around it I
you know it really lost it when you guys
started Navy different Disney does but I
do appreciate Dan's argument about how
[ __ ] knows about these streets and also
get Billy Joel out of here is the best
thing I've heard today besides which I
might be some okay alright what's the
name of that Oh whose though I should
have named the one in goofy movie who's
the massive rock star Wow stood out to
you tough tough both great both great
arguments I just said I thought Billy's
argument for shall be sort of the
natural leader who got that green of
made them cross all that territory he
was the one that made that adventure
happen I think I'm going with shadow
okay that we're tied up here um what a
fight gentlemen you know I appreciated
this sort of like he you know he's the
the heart and soul but then the the
specifics of specifically [ __ ] like
helped us like other dogs survive and
help get a fan like this sort of
specific insulate yeah oh that's why I
get it now the specificities is what won
me over so I've got a good I got to go
Dan on this one which puts us up this is
game point because it's like goofy do
for ya
from John wick which would have been a
real good dog
oh okay so let me ask you who's a good
boy oh who would be a good dog for you
oh good dog who's your best movie dog oh
well uh the the John wick dog okay again
or maybe COO joke is that dog just like
rickshaw absolutely uh kill you hey guys
game point
Billy you're leaving you sir you can
pull this around it's one of us on
number three all right what would be the
least appropriate movie to get a lego
remake oh no what would be the least
appropriate lego remake the common house
key this episode monetized
okay showgirls mm-hmm very appropriate
we've got a fight Billy when you're
ready
can you please reread the question
exactly as written I can what would make
the least appropriate movie to get a
lego remake huh showgirls is the least
appropriate anything to make so to try
to redo it in any form or fashion is
ill-advised it's also never gonna get
funnier than it exists in its current
form there's nothing that Lego can come
in and make it better
also you can't have like rape and
stripping and weird good things in a
movie like that it just doesn't work for
a lego movie there's one logical Avenue
where showgirls can go from here and
that is a Lego remake I can see it right
now let go show girls get your blocks
off
they're gonna sell this movie it makes
perfect sense it's camp and that's what
Lego does they take things that are
serious and they make a camp there's no
way to make requiem for a dream camp I
do not want to see Lego Ellen Burstyn
around a Lego subway train say like
television Liam for a dream is a movie
that kids eventually need to see because
you need to tell them about the dangers
of drugs why not give it to them in a
more digestible way which is the lego
movie but showgirls is already came
people can't go cam from camp yeah kids
you know those toys you play with why
just shoot up like Lego Johnny that's a
great idea let's make it a drug for kids
showgirls would be hilarious as a lego
movie I want to see that movie now well
done gentlemen
blocked how would that be your favorite
scene for me from Lego requiem for a
dream I'm gonna make it with my Legos
when I go home I know you are buddy
I know you are Danielle you got this
first of all showgirls is one of my
favorite movies without a doubt so this
was doubly hard for me because I want to
see showgirls as a lego movie um I do it
Billy had a great point about you can't
take camp and put camp on top of camp
showgirls is a really camping a movie so
I thought that that was a yeah I thought
that was a great point but um yeah you
really just can't show people shoot up
drugs in it it'll like a movie so I
gotta go with dad okay one vote for Dan
oh boy
one yeah who are you gonna vote for I
definitely I mean I think down the
stretch I think dad made the best point
which is yeah showgirls is already kind
of camping and silly and funny it would
be camping silly and funny to see it in
Lego rec wafer dream so so grim so
serious I just can't see
that would work I'm going with that I
have to say one last thing if you guys
have not seen the vh1 censored version
of showgirls it's worth it it's worth an
investment I don't believe it could make
a good lego movie then that's you if you
watch that if you get one thing out of
this video today it's make sure you
check out the vh1 sensor come and stop
watching myths right yeah
damn congratulations I don't know man
Harris well done gentlemen thank you so
much for fighting this weird weird fight
how Rudnick Joestar thank you for
leading the way and
being a just a delight I like sir fellas
super fun super fun I love just being
able to be just like a bunch of goofy
dip wads with you guys that was great
this is squad goals you guys Percival's
in the house hashtag alum nation and
yeah follow me at how red nick on all
the instagrams and Twitter's etc thanks
everybody
daily business yeah forever worked here
I listen movie fights the podcast
my two favorite fighters we're how and
then so this was a privilege thank you
very much
at Billy Patterson on Twitter and hub
tapes of Billy bass I think you two have
been on it already I'm here coming up
I'm still no yeah yeah check it sounds
good and thank you for your continuing
quest to find us a home dance yes I
stand by seventy percent of what I said
today
maybe thanks for watching and yeah a
really kind of that go what Joe said we
really all sorts a tomorrow we may we
don't work for defy any more but we made
a lot of friends at defy and not just
that works for defy that were part of
defies network I advise you to there are
people that are out social media right
now that are in the movie space that
also are affected by this so please
support up trying to find them yeah
exactly them support because you know
this is a really bad situation for a lot
of people and we're very lucky to be on
this end of it I look just echo that
real quick because all the people with
clever and and Smosh and just all the
cool people behind the scenes there was
a lot of good folks and I got to meet
and work with so 100% wish all of them
will hope they land on their feet and
yeah bummer of a situation yeah they
will too much talent not to London
Calling oh you're being here thanks for
having me coming over to my desk and
saying I have to be on the show
also sorry for forgetting to tell you
you had to be on the show today no prob
I don't watch our product Danielle any
shoutouts um the beams this one is a
please - Pomeranian I believe way -
Pomeranian um a lot of fun with Dan got
a lot of fun with Dan
so yeah just - just watch all the memes
as I've mentioned you know about a
podcast I've got a patreon those are
places you can support me but also throw
my hat in find all the folks from warp
zone and Smosh and from clever cuz
they're all very very talented and if
you can give them your money find a way
to do that sounds good thank you guys
very much for being here
I'm Joestar thank you guys thanks for
letting me borrow the seat this was fun
and yet to echo all the sentiments go
check those guys out we wish them all
the very best again I know what sort of
been wishy washy a little joke Ian was
sort of what's going up for us we are
fine except for the temporary nuisance
of maybe not having a home in a minute
one way or another I'm pretty sure we'll
have a show next it might not be from
this stage but we've already got some
spaces everything's cool and you guys
know what's going on but you know just
follow screen junkies on Twitter we're
pretty active on there - what are the
chances we'll be doing it from the back
of a van it's it's definitely on my
short
see you guys in the van later
[Music]